-Good luck.
-Thank you.
Where have you been?
Oh, hold up at the chateau
copulating with
a young woman named Faith.
It's ironic, isn't it?
You little devil.
Why?
-I dropped something.
-Oh, I'm sure you did.
Well, if you're going to be
cruel about it…
Don't be coming to me
for any favours.
Detective Douche is a
real joy to be around today.
I may know
the answer to that.
Another one bites the dust.
Miss Lopez, are you alright?
I can see why he had
such a meteoric rise
in the biz.
Obviously the man was
a tremendous talent.
Thank you.
Turn the music down, sir.
You should refrain from
arguing in front of the kid.
It's unbecoming.
So, you can see why
I'm having a hard time
accepting your confidence
in Miss Hodder's confession
when, in fact,
your men are still out there
looking for Miss Stangaurd
to kill her.
Yes, well.
Satan, Beelzebub,
Old Scratch…
Actually, I like that one
in particular.
But those were the old me.
These days you just have
plain old Lucifer.
You've got to admit
you've been a bit of
a selfish king,
keeping the whole
Earth thing to yourself.
Give me my son!
Over my dead body.
That's right.
It's already dead.
Not you.
Risen perfectly,
just as you like them.
You…
don't seem too bothered
by my being
the prince of darkness.
I'm willing to work
within your metaphor.
Right.
Oh.
-It's beautiful.
-Oh, it's…
What is it?
It's the bullet.
From when you shot me,
remember?
In the warehouse,
early in our partnership.
Oh.
Yeah.
I remember.
I thought since I'll…
never likely penetrate you,
I'd commemorate the one
time you penetrated me.